est-ce que l'éjaculation précoce c'est
un vrai truc
[Musique]
oui parce que ça touche 30 % des
propriétaires de pénis à un moment ou un
autre de leur vie voire plus il y a même
un sondage qui parle d'un homme sur deux
et non parce que bien souvent on utilise
le terme alors que c'est pas vraiment de
ça dont il s'agit et puis surtout parce
que c'est pas du tout une fatalité vous
allez voir qu'est-ce qu'on appelle une
dysfonction sexuelle donc ça existe
c'est même fréquent mais c'est quelque
chose de précis donc faut pas employer
le mot à temps et à travers d'ailleurs
puisqu'on en a parlé de mots on dit
quasiment plus et éjaculation précoce on
dit éjaculation prématurée ou
éjaculation rapide allez c'est parti
pour les éjaculation précoce enfin je
vous avais compris mais c'est quoi
exactement alors concrètement une
éjaculation précoce tu as trois
caractéristiques déjà elle arrive
rapidement après la pénétration
d'une minute voire deux maximum et
parfois ça peut même arriver avant la
pénétration deuxièmement il y a une
notion d'impossibilité à ce contrôler
elle arrive sans